eine neue gewissheit wir sind nicht mehr
sicher
ein neuer elfter september brutal viele
opfer im café im konzertsaal beinahe
auch im fußballstadion
dieser schlag gilt uns alle zu ahnen wir
angst geht um in europa doch wie gehen
wir mit ihr um
wir fragen den psychoanalytiker mario
kummer wie er sich diese neue
gefühlslage erklärt das unheimliche
bewirkt oder das dass das gefühl dass
heimisch science in der eigenen kultur
dass das dann in frage stellt wird also
das eindringen von der unmöglichkeit in
die gemütliche stube
das ist eigentlich was da eindringt sind
schwarze gestalten wie wir sie aus
horrorfilmen kennen die alles was wir
als kultur empfinden zerstören die angst
verbreiten durch ihre zur schau
gestellte grausamkeit unverhohlen mit
hilfe moderner medien uns ein
kriegerisches bild des islam aufdrängen
wollen angst über uns bringen wie ein
nervengift
wir haben angst vor kämpfern die
scheinbar keine angst kennen ich dir
halt die entschlossenheit mit der sie
vor und das ist eigentlich das wo
beunruhigend ist und sie hat natürlich
keine bilanz sind vollkommen umgehängt
sie sind sozusagen die waffe sauber und
könnte das massive überlegenheit
ausspielen
der überraschungseffekt das ist weiblich
das war ein medienbericht als die
pflicht auch symbolische botschaft wo
sie vermittelt mit er sich noch wenn die
auseinandersetze in die trauer mischt
sich nehmen der verunsicherung unserer
panik sie ist einer der haupt waffen des
doch die erste trotzige reaktion war ein
anderer reflex member bern wir haben
keine angst wir versuchen es mit dem
vertrauten solidarität international wie
schon im letzten januar nach den charlie
hebdo attentaten
doch etwas ist anders denn solidarität
kann nur üben wer nicht direkt betroffen
ist
und diesmal sind alle gemeint
die politik übt sich in kriegsrhetorik
markiert grimmige entschlossenheit
wir schlagen zurück wir haben das im
griff üben vergeltung
ein trostpflaster für unsere angst die
angst vor dem bse verbindet gerade alle
europäer flüchtlinge christen juden
moslems
vielleicht sind gemeinsame angstgefühle
sogar eine chance zur weltpolitischen
lösungen zu kommen
die situation in syrien im irak zu
beruhigen und auf diese weise den esc
schwäche kann man angst umwandeln kann
man angst produktiv nutzen
produktiv genutzt wäre ich aus -
erachtens nur getan weil wir eine art
verstehens bereitschaft das eigene dorf
stand in spa landschaft in eine
bestehende bereitschaft aufbringt das
heißt dass man versucht übrigens als
dialogisches selbstkritisches verhältnis
mit dem backen wird strate und sich
wirklich fragt ob im schlimmste sind was
sind seine motiv warum ist es so
sprachlos und kann mit nackter gewalt
österreich und meines erachtens bruch
was hat das mit dirk enke
wo hinter den taten
statt dass wir besser versteht und
belüfteten und irgendwie lösen findet
als magna rief masochistisch klingen
einen dialog mit einem gegner führen zu
wollen der nur töten will dennoch nur
wenn wir diesen gegner verstehen seine
motive begreifen sind wir in der lage
mit unserer angst umzugehen sie
konstruktiv zu nutzen und können unsere
handlungsfähigkeit zurückgewinnen und
den terroristen nicht den krieg erklären
den sie sich wünschen
nächste woche widmen wir die ganze
sendung den aufwühlenden ereignissen in
paris und berlin